[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ich mache heute einen shepherd's pie das
ist ein irisches rezept und ursprünglich
war das zum bauern essen oder ein
arme-leute-essen und zwar hat man da
immer übrig gebliebenes fleisch einfach
verarbeitet so eine art gulasch oder
polonaise das ganze damit um einen nicht
tomaten mit kartoffeln überbacken mit
einem kartoffelpüree und es wirklich ein
richtig richtig leckeres gericht ich
werde jetzt mit lammfleisch machen ihr
könnt aber auch natürlich zum beispiel
wind benutzen
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
füllung verwende ich drei esslöffel
olivenöl 500 gramm hackfleisch das
bereinigt gleich selber so eine zwiebel
2 knoblauchzehen zwei esslöffel
tomatenmark 250 milliliter wasser oder
brühe nicht mit wasser und habe jetzt
hier auch eine selbst gemachte brühe
ich habe hier kreuzkümmel salz und
pfeffer etwas majoran 1 lorbeerblatt
mail zum binden und dann noch ein
päckchen butter gemüse das lammfleisch
habe ich jetzt hier schon geschnitten
das jetzt lange fleisch von der keule
und ich nehme da immer gerne einfach
eineinhalb kilo macht das ganze
hackfleisch und frieden rest ein den ich
nicht brauche dann hab ich auch immer
hackfleisch da bin ich einfach mal
schnell was zubereiten will jetzt hier
einfach durch den fleischwolf geben
lammfleisch findet man auch gar nicht so
oft also da muss man bei der türkischen
metzgerei schauen da gibt es immer ich
mache trotzdem immer gerne selber und
ich kann eben auch das fleisch stück
auswählen das ich haben möchte dann muss
einfach in der fettgehalt und nicht zu
mager damit nicht trocken wird wichtig
ist nur dass lange strenge geschnitten
werden
das lifebook geben und ich schicke die
schnecke bis das fleisch durch sind
gleich was durch
nämlich hier einen gusseisernen topf
oder eine pfanne was flaches was auch
später den backofen direkt kann kann
jetzt hier das olivenöl rhein geben und
erhitzen dann das hackfleisch und den
rest friere ich wie gesagt einen 500
gramm portionen schreibt raus landkreis
und dann war es immer wieder flammt
fleisch im gefrierschrank mit schön
krümelig anbraten
hackfleisch ein bisschen verkleinern ich
hab ich die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen
bereits fein gewürfelt die werden jetzt
noch schön mit angebraten einfach
solange ein bisschen glas ist also wie
sie gar sind
hier kommt jetzt auf tomatenmark dazu
wird kurz eingerührt dann wasser oder
brühe und ich nehme jetzt wasser denn
ich habe nochmal eine selbstgemachte
brühe und da hab ich jetzt mit tomaten
brühe gemacht das habe ich wisst ihr
vielleicht noch als ich mit dem
entsafter ein video gemacht haben habe
ich ja tomatensaft und leckeren
tomatensaft gemacht und den rest aus dem
trester habe ich einfach im backofen
getrocknet der automat geht auch und
dann habe ich jetzt eben meine
gemüsebrühe selbstgemacht könnt auch
natürlich der gekaufte nehmen aber
achtet immer darauf dass einfach keine
geschmacksverstärker drin sind
jetzt aufkochen lassen und direkt die
gewürze dazu und ich finde man braucht
einfach ein bisschen kreuzkümmel das
mehl nämlich zum binden dann etwas
majoran lorbeerblatt und mit salz und
pfeffer abschmecken
ich komme jetzt noch das gemüse rein und
dann nehme ich einfach butter gemüse aus
dem tk weil es wirklich einfach ist da
hat man eine richtig schöne bunte
mischung man braucht nicht karotten
erbsen und mais extra alles ausmachen
ich habe einfach von allem ein bisschen
uns dabei blumenkohl ist dabei dass ich
jetzt ein bisschen einkochen reduziert
die hitze da sind auch schon kräuter mit
dabei und ich habe in der zwischenzeit
hier auch schon kartoffeln abgekocht die
sind noch ein bisschen warm denn daraus
werde ich jetzt das kartoffelpüree
herstellen und diese soße dies im
prinzip sobald die butter hier
geschmolzen ist und das gemüse schön
warm ist auch schon bereit
die kartoffel habe ich jetzt bereits
geschält ist dann auch noch schön warm
ich habe das kochende genommen und wenn
ihr einfach mal kartoffeln vom tag
vorher übrig habt könnt ihr einfach noch
mal ein bisschen erwärmen oder einfach
den milchreis genug machen hier werden
die jetzt nämlich auch gerade und ich
mache das jetzt hier
da brauche ich praktisch keine kartoffel
größe einfach mit dem flexi röhre die
warme milch und die butter ein bisschen
natürlich gleich nach ab und system
tierfutter geht es jetzt auch das so er
rollt doch die eine kartoffel raussuchen
das abschmecken mit salz pfeffer und
bisschen muskat was richtig genial
schmeckt ist radfahren kapazität des
bassisten so zu dem gericht und ich mag
es ganz gerne kartoffeln noch ein
bisschen stück ich sein also wenn ja
auch lieber stück ich möchte dann gerne
mit dem flexi ansonsten einfach die
kartoffelpresse benutzen oder
kartoffelstock jetzt gebe ich hier noch
etwas grammer pagano dazu für den
geschmack
[Musik]
berühren
und am besten gleich kurz abschmecken
wer noch salz oder zucker fehlt könnt
ihr jetzt nämlich noch nachwürzen
ich würde es normalerweise noch ein
bisschen chili dazu geben aber da die
kinder mitessen lasse ich grundsätzlich
schiller jetzt immer weg und wird dann
einfach meinen eigenen teil am 8
sonst können sie das nicht ist ein
bisschen scharf geht aber so ganz
persönlich jetzt habe ich beide
komponenten fertig kartoffelpüree und
die hackfleisch masse und da gibt es
wirklich verschiedene variationen ich
nehme jetzt noch eine nka schafkäse also
ein kaspar vallo käse zum überbacken
komme ich einfach nur schöne käse musste
ich denke das schmeckt uns ganz gut
schwimmen fein gerieben und jetzt kommt
alles direkt in die pfanne jetzt hier
das lorbeerblatt entfernen nicht
vergessen
dann kommt jetzt das kartoffelpüree hier
drauf und ihr könnt auch wenn es ganz
fein gemacht habt zum beispiel mit einem
spritzbeutel auftragen sowie bei diesen
königs kartoffeln wir sind herz aufgehen
hat doch noch nicht königsgarten
herzogen
ich habs jetzt abgedeckt kommst auch
erst fastenzeit ist kein fleisch
jetzt sieht man es nicht mehr jetzt
könnt ihr zum beispiel das ganze will
ich machen oder mit einer gabel
einfachen muster einziehen
ich mache jetzt mit der gabel ich nehme
jetzt einfach hier eine drehbare
tortenplatte geht es einfacher
so gefällt mir das schon richtig gut
wie gesagt könnt ihr das jetzt so schon
backen oder gerne auch noch mit bisschen
käse bestreuen
ich glaube den ganzen käse nämlich jetzt
nicht mal ein bisschen viele schöne
muster sehen und dann wird sind backofen
gebacken und ihr könnt diesen shepherd's
pie so auch schon vorbereiten und in den
kühlschrank stellen und dann verlängert
sich die backzeit einfach noch mal um
etwa 15 minuten können wir zum beispiel
am abend vorher zu bereiten für den
nächsten tag fürs mittagessen oder
morgens dann fürs abendessen sowie ihr
gerne möchte jetzt ab mit dir in den
backofen
schäfer 2 aus dem ofen geholt damit
etwas schnittlauch bestreut petersilie
geht auch die hatte ich aber leider
gerade nicht da und ich habe es auch ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen morath meckert
doch immer wenn er zu heiß probieren
muss so liebes murat line kaum
sauerstoff fleißig gearbeitet jetzt
darfst du auch was essen ja hallo ich
habe heute ich hab das garagentor grad
geputzt das ist ganz nah ich geputzt
kann schon gefallen tut es nächste mal
etwas nicht schon mal bauen wie die oli
fenster jedes einfach nur wenn man nicht
sehen oder raus doch auch hier raus
laufen
das problem ist wir haben viel glas und
dann haben wir noch glas geländer
spiegelglas türen über war ein großer
fehler
ja wir sind nicht nur noch damit
beschäftigt glas zu gucken was sie aber
echt schön oder es riecht auch richtig
gut und ich habe heute noch nichts
gegessen muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
sollten das musste ich aber zwei cafés
ihr ab heute echte jetzt aber ich habe
schon rot die gäste mit paprika und käse
es gibt dafür salat aus der recht ich
kartoffeln käse ist es oben drauf habe
ich kascha hätte die schöne schmelz
eigenschaft macht immer so schöne käse
großteil und ihnen habe ich im
kartoffelpüree noch bisschen ghana
pagano okay ich habe jetzt einfach das
futter genommen weil da die perfekte
portion an allem bunte mischung
das heißt ich denke aber es schmeckt dem
nicht nur das gesicht verzieht rasch mit
kollegen bringt mit mir schmeckt aber
aber ratter ratter schmeckst du jetzt
nur weil du hunger hast da ist ganz
wichtig wer hunger hat später lässt er
aber springt nicht genial und touren
gefallen beim case ja auch nicht immer
touren und zu arg würzige nehmen zuerst
ideal weil weil er bei bis zu 40 dann
dran dann schmeckt also nur noch würze
englisch richtig genial schlechter nur
hammer und wirklich ein gericht was ihr
super vorbereiten können müssen sich
shepherd's pie musste das hauptgeschäft
die jungs haben und die wussten
ich habe es ja auch schon gefragt der
schmeckt jetzt ohne dieses charisma
okay das mache ich echt super einfach
mal wenn ihr mal kartoffeln übrig habt
man tritt meistens nur einmal ja nicht
weiter und macht das bild es gibt so
lieblingsrezept also wirklich hinter
rezepte die mache ich dann halt immer
mal wieder weil sie super einfach sind
zum beispiel diese orientalische wort
fahne mit den kita erbsen und den
joghurt die mache ich echt auf
normalerweise nicht kommt ja es stimmt
dass wir echte rezepte können eine
abwandlung machen und abwandlungen euro
war inszeniert war sehr gut das freut
mich also morath dir noch guten appetit
euch viel spaß machen das rezept findet
ihr auf sase - blog.de
wir können ja mal schreiben was bisher
ultimatives lieblingsrezept auf meinem
kanal war süß und herzhaft wie dem bitte
macht es noch wirklich der fest jetzt
wirklich der wahnsinn endlich wenn du
glücklich bin ich auch was soll ich noch
so aber ja
haben vielleicht nicht die kirchen
europas echter hammer
[Musik]